noi siamo per oggi
ciao a tutti benvenuti a feroci nella
scorsa puntata abbiamo avuto l'occasione
di poter fare un viaggio all'interno
della mente dell'essere umano esplorando
soprattutto alle zone più scure della
psiche oggi proveremo ad analizzare
l'anima e trovare la nostra identità
spirituale per affrontare questo viaggio
abbiamo chiamato qui la medium giordano
allora nome già a giordano professione
medium a un academy dove insegna a
trovare il proprio spirito
mediatico mediatico e credo che sia
medianico media hanno l'aggettivo di
medium mediano ha scoperto le sue
qualità quattro anni quando l'hanno
vista camminare mano nella mano con
un'entità quindi anche gli altri però
avevano un dono perché se lo vedi no ma
credo che l'abbiano vista tipo temere un
cieco sanno è
quindi adesso e hanno anche aveva
avrebbero dato dei farmaci semplicemente
prese abilità a sviluppatori uscire dal
suo corpo ma non abbiamo capito dove lo
effettua una lettura di tarocchi
quantica in radianti personali e ho
detto tutto perché non hai idea di cosa
sia ragazzi i suoi adepti li chiama
figli di luce di tutte queste
presentazione abbiamo capito soltanto
che si chiama george or die cast
veramente ragazzi che il resto solo dire
a lei intima forza non si parte mai
prevenuti io farò del mio meglio
tutti quanti faremo del nostro meglio
per cui possiamo accogliere giovani e io
direi di sì è in triggio ha usato 7
accenti locali benvenuta ti chiedo
subito la prima cosa la giusta pronuncia
del tuo nome joe ha sì semplice gioco
l'accento sulla ok che l'aveva beccato
giusto tu forse io ma non so se ogni
tanto aspiravo sul papa chiede ci ho già
parlato qualche anno fa telepaticamente
e cosa ci siamo detti
è successo allora quando ho visto
michele per la prima volta ho detto è
nato un altro poeta il poeta dell'anima
e quindi ho detto ad alessia che lavora
con me da dieci anni ho detto io lo
voglio incontrare e quindi un universo
mi ha risposto sì ringrazio me piace
sempre la lusinga quindi ti ringrazio ti
faccio una domanda siamo noi in questa
stanza ove di delle cose ci sono altre
entità
ok siete da soli non siamo da soli
partiamo dall'inizio
pagato subito ma di sapere quanti
eravamo tanti che bambina e ridà piccola
innanzitutto una bambina medianica sono
nata così mio padre è deceduto in un
incidente stradale a soli 37 anni tutto
padre l'hai conosciuto in vita avevo tre
anni e mezzi nino te lo ricordi di te io
ho vissuto con lui il suo lo gramma se
vogliamo direi del suo corpo spirituale
che mi ha accompagnato sempre e nel
momento della celebrazione religiosa mi
hanno visto con la manina che camminava
con la manina in alto tenendo la mano di
mio padre quindi tu lo vedevi sì quali
sono le abilità che tu hai sviluppato
vabbè quando ero bambina i canali erano
tutti aperti la visione e la chiara
udienza in maniera naturale in cui è
successo un momento molto difficile
della mia vita perché a 10 anni ho
tentato il suicidio mi sentivo fuori da
questa terra e quindi questa diversità
pesava volevo raggiungere mio padre
quindi ho preso tutte le pillole di
casale o ingoiate e in quel momento è
arrivato mio padre e con le mie guide di
rocchi sono le guide che mi hanno detto
ricordati chi sei e quindi quello è
stato un momento per me di rinascita
sono rimasta da sola 22 anni con tre
figli però poi ho mantenuto la mia
decisione solo da sola sono una medium
sono un'artista dipingo e posso lavorare
noi abbiamo scaricato effettivamente il
materiale che ci hai mandato con quella
in meta visione in pratica
c'erano delle medium di udine che hanno
scattato a canale vuoto con questa
immagine e io sapevo che era mio padre
mio padre era effettivamente così prova
a fare un po
la la posizione antipatica del dello
scettico no adesso tu mi fai vedere
questa meta visione del questo rumore
bianco no sul televisore da cui esce il
volto di tuo padre mi ricordo che ci fu
un caso credo al sud se non sbaglio però
dell'apparizione del volto di padre pio
su un portone questa cosa fece molta
notizia per poi scoprire che si trattava
di un banalissimo sensales si tratto di
un fallo quindi ci fu una cosa che poi
ironicamente fuori presa tanto per una
persona scettica ti dico che a volte il
cervello codifica quello che in quel
momento ho bisogno quando è in una
situazione di stress molto spesso le
nostre sinapsi vanno in corto circuito
e se abbiamo bisogno di avere
un'immagine che ci sostiene avviene io
sono una persona abbastanza difficile
cioè sono figlio di mio padre in questo
molto molto concreto ea me di ammetterlo
capitano volte cose strane per esempio
una cosa che a me capita e la sera io
sento
le voci ma di voci di persone che
conosci e o che non conosco non mi fa
mai paura tu come le gestivo io le
giustifico pensando e anzi credendo che
siano una sorta di momento di torni via
trans cioè la mia testa stessa che me la
fa sentire non è che penso di captare
qualcosa di esterno potresti essere un
antenna
ogni cosa che viene detto al 100 domande
svolgerò e fanno sicura un attimo di
confusione c'è mai stato una situazione
dove un'entità giusto e corretto
chiamarle così faceva paura no la paura
è stato quando non li ho più sentiti per
un periodo e quando è successo quando ho
deciso di sposarvi un uomo che non amavo
sono stata in un momento di conflitto
terribile ho cominciato a dire a dio
padre se se mio padre perché non
rispondi allora un certo punto cadono i
quadri della stanza ed io li sento
scivolare sul letto e planare e mai se
mi hanno detto ricordati quello che è
scelto e quindi ho fatto tutto un
percorso con degli sciamani ho fatto
delle iniziazioni sciamaniche poi
arrivata alessia dieci anni fa e abbiamo
aperto la accademia di formazione dove
io aiuto le persone a vedere questo ma è
lo devo dire perché è una figlia
meravigliosa qui con me li mi è stata
annunciata da padre pio lui mi ha detto
avrai una figlia femmina quindi ora già
divorziata ero ospite a torino non è di
uno italo peruviana vedeva un'entità
vicino a me di un templare ok ho
un'amica e che dico
nadia mai un amico che si occupa di
templarismo le fasi 1 molto strano sai
devo dare un messaggio entro nel suo
studio in quel momento io dico mi faccia
sentire le sue mani metto le mani su e
in cui radiante vedo che lui era un
templare e io ero la donna che l'aveva
fatto beccare quindi alzo le mani
scapoli e ma questo è tipo visione di
una vita passata
e possibile quindi io sono scappata lui
mi ha cercato per quasi sei mesi e poi
nata la nostra storia ed è nata
francesca alla porta
adesso
ok adesso ripiegato il papà di francesca
era stato annunciato dalla frana che
vedeva un templare al tuo fianco ora ci
sono chi odia che se stessa cosa anch'io
che ci sono anch'io scusami se sono
invadente tutto era stato insieme certo
ok non è che per caso vedi un templare
vicino a
meno te lo dico non c'è nulla per ora
hai un fratello stellare ma chi siamo il
di rotello io ok non dello stellare
venuto da un'altra galassia
cioè cos'è cos'è un fratello stellare
lui è diventato tuo fratello
consanguineo sta lì ma al 3 stalli tipo
sei tu
cioè no
questa la voglio sapere subito cioè
quindi fermi e ferma giorgio allora per
favore il fatto mi ha invitato sono una
mia e di un vedo
quindi jamaran mark gianmarco allora
quando tu hai deciso di venire sulla
terra nel quarto piano di esistenza
viene detto o iv c è lo chi sono gli
accordi ha nemici in tre anime quindi in
quell'accordo c'era anche lui c'è quindi
noi ci siamo beccati abbiamo detto o
facciamo che siamo parenti certo siete
contenti di questa scelta che aver
ripreso nel quarto cielo oppure vi siete
pentiti ma io
adesso soft key tenermi molto stretto
insomma io vorrei accedere a un momento
per noi molto importante ragazzi se vi
va il momento delle domande
diciamo importanti tipo che sparano
l'anima esiste esiste allo stato di
coscienza superiore la morte un mezzo
però noi siamo eterni quindi prendiamo
la persona a caso lollo continua quindi
una volta
chiarito questo percorso si a esistere
come lollo barolo è affare non più pit
stop lui continua a vivere quando
parallelo lui crea il mondo che conosce
potrebbe anche fare ti tocca in un mondo
invisibile ma nel mondo parallelo sarà
circondato dalle stesse persone di
questo mondo non sempre
è quindi una parte della nostra
coscienza rimane tu rimarrai in un mondo
dove conosci l'altro te perché mi siamo
uno ma siamo tanto deciderà di tornare
in questa ruota della vita che è un loop
temporale fino a che non hai deciso di
andare in un'altra dimensione già un
momento qui hai fatto un'affermazione
importante cioè quindi teoricamente
michele per esempio facciamo finta che
si è reincarnato in questa è questa vita
michele è stato in spagna nel 1700
eccoci anche recentemente comunque
è cosa facevo in spagna nel 1700 cosa
faceva sparire
signore abbastanza importante dava
lavoro agli altri ed è andato via
giovanissimo per un amore impossibile h
pure nelle vite
kimi ha ucciso e l'amore no joey dire è
a questo tavolo c'è l'ipotesi li facevi
una cosa pazzesca
se ti dicessi che se tutti delle
plausibile perché io io vi vedo insieme
a noi due in un momento importante
passiamo aveva doppiato da sole
che sono aspetta allora in una vita
passata se fosse l'insieme la
sincronicità fra di voi c'è una bella
armonia vi comprendete anche senza
parlare ma scusa ma lui è stato un amore
impossibile un amore buon'ora imposi
valore che ha ucciso le trame per
gelosia io ho ucciso lui per gelosia o
tradito e sicuramente ecco
un'altra delle cose che mi perseguita
anche in questa vita alla protesta
veri michele bellissimo che sta questa
san marco è uno star si vuol dire uno
star sid che le due coscienze si
uniscono e
materializzano il corpo fisico alla
spesso e marcone combinato il sacco è
questa ma che nei fatti
ha fatto bene a fare quello che ho fatto
qual è quindi la differenza in questo
momento fra gian marco e michele star
site che è in un momento c'è stata
proprio questa comunione della famiglia
stellare lui ha detto che scendo io tu
sei un leonide una razza bellissima si
occupa dell'amore di proteggere la vita
di andare fino in fondo vedi tu non hai
saputo perdonarmi
mentre lollo scusa lollo lollo deve
prendere ancora consapevolezza di chi è
e lo vuole mostrare e dire questo sono
io tanta roba che se qui a lavorare non
è che c'è sempre un cazzo che di levare
essere focus è invece nel caso tuo
allora mi è stato detto che dicendo does
garda anche se un mito è quello di torre
e non lo vedi
no
veramente alto mi occupo insegno le rune
urlato urlato qui vuol dire urlato nel
senso cioè
come se fosse in chat capire col sorriso
ma anche sembrato io vi voglio portare
due esperienze aria il giusto
mi è stato detto che ci avevo parlato di
ariel io ero già pronto con la coda
sirena mi sono detto non quello che
pensi giusto o no assolutamente
ariel è una ragazza che il 25 di agosto
fa 16 anni il giovedì santo
io ero in accademia stavo facendo le
sessioni individuali arriva questo
messaggio terribile dove ariel ha avuto
un incidente ho detto ad alessia la
situazione è gravissima vedo il sangue
vedo un emorragia interna
elias porteranno la milza così è stato
io mi sto battendo perché mi occupo di
tantissime cose quali la guarigione ma
che occupi della guarigione nhtsa suo
spirituale un senso fisico in senso
anche fisico non posso dividere lo
spirituale dal fisico quindi c'è nel
senso che non hai una fiducia nei
confronti della scienza io sono la prima
che vada dal medico io ho una capacità
naturale anche questa di uscire fuori
dal corpo quindi il mio corpo astrale
sono entrata nella sala operatoria e
l'ho assistita
i medici pensavano che aria non ce
l'avrebbe fatta invece a real me la sono
andata a riprendere quindi cosa succede
doveva stare in coma farmacologico ma
con le mie tecniche
il giorno dopo era già sveglia infatti i
medici stessi dicono ariel è un miracolo
quindi tu eri la ma in realtà doveri
nella sala operatoria con il mio corpo
astrale il tuo corpo da fuori sembra che
sta dormendo fondamentalmente
normalmente io ho una medianità attiva
posso parlare con te ma posso stare
anche in un altro posto e
ariel stava non era nel suo corpo cioè
la mostra le era in giro le ho visto una
luce ha visto suo nonno
ok e la richiamavo ad entrare nel suo
corpo perché lei aveva deciso di morire
non sono nessuno per dire questo è vero
questo è falso io vengo da una famiglia
di medici quindi sono molto attaccato a
un discorso scientifico e mi è più
facile affidarmi a quella rotta sono un
po san tommaso onestamente e ho paura
anche sai nel tuo mondo c'è anche tanta
sono anche tanti ciarlatani parla male
però è difficile per uno che non conosce
il tuo mondo distinguere perché chiunque
ti dice che lui non ha un ciarlatano è
molto difficile da importante fare
l'esperienza propria perché io ti posso
raccontare tutto ma se tu non vivi
l'esperienza non certo la tua percezione
sarà sempre di fidenza io so che tu fai
una cosa che si chiama tipo lettura
dell'aura nel campo allora io insegno
una tecnica che si chiama quanti power
noi abbiamo questo campo intorno a lui
che comunemente si chiama aurea che io
so quindi che tu riuscissi a leggere
diciamo questo campo ma allo stesso
tempo anche a leggere quello che
l'animale l'animale di potere a girare
di poteri una persona ma quindi possiamo
scoprire sia il campo si muovono se non
sono sempre gli stessi
io sono pronto ma epico un padrone
mi sono sentito un po lollo
adirato in
esercitazioni doverose attraverso il tuo
campo lollo io vedo un orso l'orso è un
animale di potere che ci aiuta a
smembrare il mondo vecchio quindi ci
sono delle cose che non devi più
portarti nell'intimo di te stesso e
l'orso ti dice tu hai le qualità esprimi
le ma vai oltre io credo che tu abbia
avuto un orso a casa ma io ho visto che
c'era veramente il
oddio oddio se tiri fuori quindi the
pooh giuro che mi è
tipo un orsetto di legno ad esempio c'è
una danza bellissima con l'orso e c'è
anche un canto se tu e chiamare il tuo
orso c'è il canto morto
poi te la dico tutta l'asia beh se non
lo fai un alloggio lo è
si fa quattro volte a tutela insegna da
grazia e se non mi fai un balletto anche
sul titolo si chiami loro che mi faccio
certo farlo se tolgo il saluto hashtag
virale
mentre invece michele michele vedo un
cavallo bianco e 15 pegaso indirizza
verso la strada del tuo successo
cavalieri dello zodiaco
mi chiamo figo sono ragazzi grazie a
questo punto ci sono anch'io dai dai che
ospitiamo un cornuto
anch'io quando il progresso cadavere con
fuori non si arriva selvaggia successo
la gente spagna esatto allora per te
vedo un lupo bianco in questo momento
sai nel viaggio sciamanico il lupo è
colui che va nel mondo di sotto e un
mondo dove si incontrano gli i maestri
che danno messaggi
ispirazione volontà il lupo a volte
solitario perché sceglie di essere
solita una grazia giovane spiegano anche
questa cosa perché io per te vorrei
stare da solo ma le persone sono
asfissianti talvolta io non riesco a
trovare un modo carino per dire
scrostate una frase che diventa oggi io
sono con il mio lupo ok perfetto che lui
dice spesso in realtà per riferito ad
altre cose
a chi va con lo zoppo impara a zoppicare
michele ci sei allora sono su un cavallo
alato mette invece sul solo artipo a
lollo una lettura del campo come
funziona per cioè allora lollo a questi
colori che si alternano quindi il suo
colore verde del cuore lo vedo in questo
momento che è come se pulsar tdv
innamorare loro
ragazzi
cosa come dobbiamo fare qua di m
scrivetemi in di m ragazzi secondo me
c'è solo che tu non lo vedi la dc che
c'è
l'amore il cielo di design o sei troppo
preso da te stesso in questo ko capi
certo ahi ahi un bisogno di un paese non
le nego e fame di trovare il proprio
percorso per cui in realtà nel momento
in cui non sa dove mettere i piedi come
può alzare la testa e vedere che c'è una
persona che sta guardando da lontano
gen si aiuta mentono per favore allora
metti la mano qui allora attraverso il
tuo campo vedo dicembre che c'è un
cambiamento per te ok c'è la voglia di
andare a esplorare qualche città nuova
devi solo saper scegliere quindi non
scegliere con la testa ma scegli con la
vibrazione del cuore e che tu non ti
fidi abbastanza quindi vai oltre che
statua sentire e usa il tuo cuore ok
meraviglierà villoso vabbè stupro
posso dire una cosa che mi è venuto in
mente che io ho tanto riso scherzato
detto e non detto ma in realtà io vengo
da una famiglia
diciamo una storia familiare abbastanza
particolare perché io sono tipo per tre
quarti siciliano e la mia bisnonna
faceva le sedute spiritiche e una cosa
che dicevano infatti quando vai poi a
parlare con tipo i miei nonni e
compagnia bella è che succedevano cose
stranissime a casa nostra tanto che
quando poi lei è morta nella casa dove è
morta sono iniziate a suscitare accadere
cose strane io non ho mai testimoniato
questa roba ma in otto persone e alcuni
queste persone sono presenti in questa
stanza e possono giocare
la notte sentivano dei passi che
salivano e scendevano le scale tanto che
un giorno questi passi sono stati così
evidenti che tutti quanti si sono messi
ad aspettare che spuntasse qualcuno
della porta ma non è mai arrivata con la
persona che tutti quanti pensavano ci
fosse qualcuno fermo come un cretino
capito da attende di fare l'ultimo
scalino loro l'hanno
diciamo chiamato il barone sanguinario
ah ok una casa serena in casa serena io
dormivo nell'altra casa quindi non
sapevo nulla la cosa particolare che mio
fratello con la coda dell'occhio un
giorno vide una figura che scambiò per
mia zia che trascinava i piedi sul
pianerottolo e camminava tanto la foto
sia senti ma non sa caro minimamente
scende giù la becca in mezzo al giardino
sé ma ti stavo parlando due secondi fast
sopra che fine ha fatto qual è la favola
lei non era suo ma effettivamente la
bisnonna aveva una fisicità simile a
quella di mia zia e strusciava le scarpe
sul pavimento quindi questa cosa le
ciabatte diciamo come se avesse di
questo caso quindi io mi ricordo solo
una cosa era periodo natalizio perché
poi quando è successo mi sono rifugiato
sotto l'albero dal terrore praticamente
apro la porta di questo disimpegno che
mi avrebbe portato poi al piano sotto ho
visto una specie di non figura perché
dire figura è sbagliato era una roba
molto nebbiosa
con un volto o dio che mi è arrivata
addosso velocissimo c'è stato il
secondo è visto reporter
dello shejiang quella casa là in mezzo
alle case loro entrano e c'è al bus che
mi è venuta contro io mi sono buttato di
spalle e ho avuto una sensazione di
freddo addosso bruttissima preso non ho
mai raccontato a nessuno essere anche un
ectoplasma come quello che ha visto tuo
fratello però non era accesa di suo ma
sarà proprio l'ectoplasma il corpo
astrale dei nostri cari che non sono più
qui sulla terra però l'ho vissuta
proprio con cattiveria
non so se è stato solo la mia paura di
qualcosa che non conoscevo però proprio
terrorizzato terrorizzato sono quelle
forme energetiche di intelligenze che ci
attraversano
scusate qualcuno si è fatto la barba non
sto morendo
e
impulsivo siete troppo belli ti posso
chiedere scusa io ti perdono e averti
ucciso io ti chiedo scusa per averti
cornificati esatto esatto ma io credo
che entrambi abbiamo imparato qualcosa
io che la violenza non è mai una
risposta e io che ti posso solo essere
amico
c'è qualche altra cosa che voi volete
chiedere dichiara so che è la lista e
io non finisco più quanto tempo abbiamo
finito
io credo che la cosa più giusta il
garante si possa fare invece chiedere a
te già c'è qualcosa invece tra i mille
argomenti che abbiamo coperto che
vorresti o ribadire oche vorresti dire a
me piacerebbe tornare perché vi adoro
siete simpaticissimi
poi anche la missione che avete di
parlare ai giovani è il mio stesso
intento quindi o anche nelle mie serate
o giovani che arrivano e quindi mi
piacerebbe continuare perché non lo dico
in diretta perfetto occhio a quello che
si desidera perché poi si manifesta
giusto desidero è il mio intento perché
il desiderio a volte crea falle sono le
intenzioni certo che creano la manifesta
la manifestazione grazie mille giò per
essere stata con gravissimi però ragazzi
siamo rimasti noi queste questa tua
puntata post aveva tante informazioni è
troppe forse ma voi ci avete creduto ma
più o meno benché abbia amato dovessero
questa questa chiacchiera e amato anche
joan davanti al dubbio dirò sempre notte
poi torno alla mia voce da doppiatore
voce e soprattutto leggi e un attimo il
finale spetta perché qua occhiale subito
grazie
sembra sempre cento un tabagista
grazie per averci seguito la prossima
puntata verrà vedrà come ospite in
primis uno scienziato mental coach
evolutivo ma soprattutto per me mio
padre a questo chiaramente alla scritto
giuliano stessa il papa dei gioielli
sarà mio papà ragazzi e assurdo che una
persona che ho sempre nascosto
all'occhio di internet e capiremo perché
c'è lo capiremo insieme per la prima
volta su questi schermi verrà a farci
visita giuseppe scilla
preparatevi perché c'è un motivo per cui
non ho mai condiviso ma almeno a
modificare in terza persona che sono
monotematico mi piace dare voce a te
stesso con lui ci avventure hanno
aspetto ha cambiato come sono entrato in
me stesso adesso dovrà rientrare con lui
ci avvicineremo nel mondo del potere dei
desideri in quella che sarà una
chiacchiera a metà tra scienza e magia e
che tirerà un po le fila delle prime
puntate di questo podcast da noi feroci
e tutto ragazzi e ragazze un grafico
serviva una cosa tipo un vostro commento
di
regole roccia uno spregio income allora
concludiamo la citata grazie a loro mi
sta tremando il culo
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]